You did a real a lot of hard work to
become an actor you started at a young age.
And to me when I look at this, you
know, you're going out on auditions at like I guess
I'm going to say 8 years old when you start?
Yeah, I was 8 right. I was 8.
I guess you were rejected for a couple of
commercials and you say as an eight-year-old
I don't like doing commercials I'm not gonna do it, I'm only doing film right you announced that to your mom.
I mean that's a prettysophisticated concept you would think you'd say,
"Hey whatever work I can get iIm going to take!" But no you're only a film actor.
Who the hell did I think I was?
Yeah who were you that you wouldeven have that idea? So at how old are you when you debut off Broadway with Ethan Hawke?
I think I was 8.
You probably say to yourself at 8, "If
I'm off broadway with Ethan Hawke this career is kind of easy i don't know what all these adultsare complaining about"
Do you have this sort of delusion that
this is just going to be the simplest thing ever?
Well I definitely wasn't
delusional because I was putting in the legwork
You know and I mean I was like I said I
was going on a lot of auditions and I was being
rejected most of the time right and then you knowI think what happens is when you're a kid actor
and you book a job -- the first film
that I did was a movie called "North" that
Rob Reiner directed and I had a small part in thatand you know, but when you're a kid actor it's
different than being you know an adult.
I think casting directors realize they can depend
on you because you're kind of a professional
kid right and so you know directors sort of
look at the reel of actors, kid actors that are
already working because they know that there's a
a vocabulary that you understand um
you know and it gives them some comfort I think.
At 10 years old you're at the Lee Strasberg schoolfor acting, everyone in the class is an adult
there's no other 10 year old.
Yeah well I wasin their kids class and then the second year I moved into the like
kind of older kids class.
Kids that are mostly 17, 18.
Were you a prodigy? I mean you skipped from the 10 year olds right up to the 17 year olds! Did they consider you as somesort of superstar even then?
I really don't know how I gotinto that class.
Don't you become full of yourself when suddenly you're like, "Hey, fuck you 10 year old she's with the 17 year olds."
That would be like if i was playing in a little
league and then they brought me to the pros
You know what i mean it's like a big step!
I don't know I don't think i was full of myself
but it's hard to remember I mean I'm an actor soobviously there's a certain level of narcissism.
Were the other people at Lee Strasbourg uh
were they jealous of you because you had been
Off Broadway and like you said you already werecast in Rob Reiner's "North" right?
Which was at the time you know Rob Reiner
he had a string of hits.
He was one of the biggest directors yeah it was a good timefor him. I don't know I mean I don't remember kids
being particularly mean to me but maybe that'sjust because I was
I was a pretty low-key kid. I wasn't very
flashy or showy or anything when you go to regular
school though and you're not at least to a regularpublic school but for me like who went to see
"Sophistry" with Ethan Hawke Off Broadway? Like nobodygave a shit you know?
As a little girl were you just enamored with Ethan Hawke?
I was enamored with Ethan Hawke. Oh my god totally. I was just absolutely -- and this was like, '90-whatever.
1995 or something like that so that was that wasprime.
Because he represents what you wanted tobe be right? He was a successful working actor.
And he was also gorgeous and like this you know guy
and young guy in his 20s that was like you knowsmoking four cigarettes at once and it's like his
Kangol was flipped backwards or whatever. Do youstill know Ethan Hawke is that a relationship?
I do I mean it's so funny to see him of course
now she's like you're that little girl
I acted with right yeah yeah it's got to be
weird it must be weird because I have boobs now.